c'est fait après 55 jours de confinement
nous voici arrivés à destination
prêt pour ouvrir les portes et découvrir
le monde extérieur je suis content le
vaisseau a tenu le coup et vous aussi
bon le décor a un peu changé
souvenez vous tout a commencé ici au
pied de ce promu il était alors en
fleurs aujourd'hui il est couvert de
feuilles et portent des fruits
je vous aimerai bien montrer mais chaque
matin il ya un couple pigeon ramier qui
vient et prendre son petit déjeuner
[Musique]
pendant cette traversée je vous ai
également parlé de mon compost depuis je
les utilisais g planter des fraisiers du
persil de la salade des betteraves
promis on fera la récolte ensemble j'ai
aussi réalisé des jardinières vous
souvenez de la menthe et j'ai semé des
tomates qui sont en train de lever aller
dans l'atelier maintenant pendant ces 55
jours la terre à tourner je vous ai
parlé de sa vitesse de rotation de sa
position autour du soleil qui changent
au fil des saisons nous sommes passés de
l'hiver au printemps elle a grondé aussi
sur l'île de la réunion le volcan est
entré en éruption
la lune a également fait le tour de la
terre et elle continue de nous présenter
toujours la même face quel voyage nous
avons décollé avec des fusées nous
sommes approchés des nuages d'un trou
noir des trous dans le fromage est aussi
du petit trou percé dans la colonne d'un
stylo bille et faute de vous parler du
chas de l'aiguillé
et bien je vous ai présenté ni trop mon
petit chat adoré
je tenais également à vous adresser un
immense merci aux élites cette aventure
et il n'y avait pas de chaîne youtube
vous avez eu raison d'insister
avant-hier la barre des 400 mille
abonnés a été franchi sur ma chaîne et
comme un bonheur n'arrive jamais seul
vous avez également franchi la barre des
300 mille abonnés sur twitter et vous
êtes désormais plus de 200 mille fans
sur facebook
merci pour votre enthousiasme vos
encouragements votre envie de découvrir
le monde de mel et connaissances et
poésie merci aux scientifiques aux
experts aux enseignants qui ont bien
voulu me donner un petit peu de leur
temps pour répondre à mes questions
quand je voulais vérifier ou approfondir
tel ou tel point alors rassurez vous on
ne va pas se quitter
pendant ces 55 jours nous avons beaucoup
ri pas que le 1er avril on a pleuré
aussi et ça c'était à cause des zones où
les liens que nous avons tissés sont
trop forts je vais donc continuer à vous
faire découvrir les coulisses du monde
qui nous entoure
j'ai plein de belles histoires à vous
raconter deux phénomènes à vous
expliquer deux sites à vous faire
découvrir de gens à vous faire
rencontrer
dernière chose bravo à la petite caméra
et à ses petites mains qui ont fabriqué
tous les accessoires que j'ai utilisé
j'allais oublier les escargots
vous aussi vous êtes des confiné et vous
avez raison vous avez tout votre temps
il ya tellement de belles choses à
découvrir derrière le mur à l'est a très
vite demain matin nous serons des
confiné mais nous restons lien à très
bientôt pour de nouvelles capsules 2d
confiné version l'homme vaut vous pouvez
les mamans voir ou revoir toutes celles
qui ont été publiés pendant le
confinement il vous suffit de cliquer
sur la gauche et pour être sûr de ne pas
louper les prochaines et bien
abonnez vous à très bientôt et prenez
soin de vous